Горять боєприпаси: велика пожежа в Ґруневальді
Боротьба з вогнем: лісові пожежі в Бранденбурзі
Бої навколо АЕС: у фокусі Запоріжжя
В ефірі «heute journal»
з Ханною Ціммерман і Крістіаном Зіверсом.
Добрий вечір усім.
Ліс Ґруневальд - це не лише дерева,
які поросли на площі у понад 4500 га.
Це місце відпочинку для мешканців мегаполіса,
а також «зелені легені» Берліна та місце,
яке люди люблять й оспівують.
Зараз цей ліс охоплений полум'ям.
Лісова пожежа на околицях великого міста
становить неабияку загрозу,
оскільки серед дерев розташований
склад вибухівки й боєприпасів,
які належать поліції.
Через таку небезпеку пожежникам
важко наблизитися до території, охопленої вогнем.
Автомагістраль AVUS та залізничні колії
повністю заблоковані.
Подробиці - в сюжеті Крістгарда Леппле.
Ці кадри нагадують війну.
Рано-вранці пролунали вибухи.
Палає не деінде,
а серед берлінського лісу Ґруневальд,
на відгородженій території для знищення боєприпасів.
Піротехнічні вироби й боєприпаси
спричинили пожежу в лісі.
Ми зустріли велосипедиста,
який їхав на роботу
паралельно до автомагістралі AVUS.
Він не повірив своїм очам.
Мене це дійсно лякає й хвилює.
Люди завжди думають,
що глобальне потепління їх омине,
а зараз я безпосередньо відчуваю загрозу,
і до того ж дуже близько.
Місце дії - «зелені легені» Берліна, ліс Ґруневальд
недалеко від автомагістралі AVUS
та жвавої залізничної колії.
Ліс посохнув
від спеки без дощу.
Пожежа почалася о 3:30
саме на території для знищення боєприпасів,
серед ночі.
Аж до вечора працівникам екстрених служб
не вдавалося почати гасіння вогню.
Ми припускаємо,
що рівень температури й забруднення ґрунту
на території для знищення боєприпасів
надзвичайно високий.
Інакше за 14 годин після першого
сигнального оповіщення
не почалась би така детонація,
яку ми чуємо просто зараз.
Тут дуже шумно.
1000-метрова кільцева огорожа досі стоїть.
Пожежа триває.
Причину її виникнення ще не з'ясовано.
Приблизно 250 працівників екстрених служб
поки нічого не можуть вчинити,
окрім як стримувати осередок займання.
Вони сподіваються, що ситуація не погіршиться.
Автомагістраль AVUS буде заблокована
до шостої ранку завтра.
Головне запитання: чи має сенс використовувати
територію Ґруневальда для знищення боєприпасів?
За даними поліції, тут зберігаються
приблизно 25 тонн вибухових пристроїв,
зокрема боєприпаси часів Другої світової війни
і піротехнічні вироби.
Тут їх знешкоджували фахівці.
Чинна бургомістерка спеціально
прибула з відпустки до місця події.
Це унікальний випадок,
перший за всю повоєнну історію Берліна.
Зайнялася територія лісу
навколо місця знищення боєприпасів.
Мешканці столиці вже давно вимагали
припинити знищення боєприпасів на цій території.
Ми маємо радше думати про те,
що робити в майбутньому з цим місцем,
і чи дійсно воно має бути на території Берліна.
В екстрених випадках допомагає Теодор, робот
у лавах земельного управління кримінальної поліції.
Він може знайти вибухівку
на заблокованій території, охопленій вогнем,
проаналізувати її та знешкодити.
Та для робота теж існують межі,
як і для пожежних літаків.
Над територією знищення боєприпасів
заблокований навіть повітряний простір
на висоті до 1000 метрів.
Ми маємо розуміти, що кожний метр,
який ми проходимо в заблокованій зоні,
може становити небезпеку
для працівників екстрених служб.
У цій ситуації ми розраховуємо на те,
що вночі продовжуватимуть лунати вибухи,
і ми отримаємо доступ до території
не раніше завтрашнього ранку.
Єдина хороша новина з Берліна цього спекотного дня -
це те, що життю людей нічого не загрожувало.
З нами на зв'язку з місця подій голова земельної
пожежної служби Берліна, Карстен Гомріггаузен.
Добрий вечір.
Чи вдалося Вашим співробітникам
взяти вогонь під контроль?
Нині навколо місця для знищення боєприпасів
обгородили зону радіусом 1 км.
Оскільки ми не хочемо наражати людей на небезпеку,
ми не можемо проникнути всередину,
щоб розпочати гасіння пожежі.
Тож наразі ми чекаємо.
Звісно, ми боремося з вогнем,
який виходить за огороджену зону.
Однак в межах розвідувальної роботи
нам потрібно вирішити,
що робити з боєприпасами, охопленими полум'ям.
Чи можете Ви більше розповісти про проблеми,
з якими зіткнулися на місці?
Чи мали Ви схожий досвід?
Особисто я не мав.
Багато моїх колег - теж.
Це дуже особливий виїзд.
Його особливість полягає в тому,
що тут ми маємо справу з залишками боєприпасів
і речовин, які детонують.
Ми мусимо вирішувати на місці
разом з іншими службами,
що робити з цими боєприпасами, які там горять.
Ми отримали сигнал тривоги сьогодні о 3:30 ранку
і виїхали на об'єкт.
Після першої детонації наш диспетчер
негайно наказав відходити,
адже була загроза нашому життю.
Згодом, приблизно о 18:30,
сталася ще серія вибухів залишків боєприпасів.
Тому, як ви можете бачити, ситуація наразі нестабільна.
Як ви вважаєте, що спричинило цю ситуацію?
Що було перше: пожежа чи вибухи?
Про це можна лише здогадуватися,
але це нам покажуть результати розслідування
причин виникнення пожежі.
Це головне завдання поліції в Берліні.
Навіщо зберігати боєприпаси в лісі,
у зоні відпочинку для мешканців Берліна?
Чи це безпечно на думку пожежної служби?
Я можу сказати,
що ситуація могла б бути
значно складнішою.
Так, якби житлова забудова була ближче,
то сьогодні ми б мали справу з титанічним завданням:
здійснювати евакуацію
й слідкувати за тим, куди розлітаються
уламки, снаряди та інші рештки боєприпасів.
Тож з перспективи практичної пожежної безпеки
розташування складу в лісі має свої переваги.
Хіба не краще було б працювати з боєприпасами
десь за межами великого міста?
Це, звісно, потрібно обговорювати
і запитувати про це відповідальних людей.
Пожежна служба Берліна за це не несе відповідальності.
Наше завдання - вживання заходів безпеки на місцях.
З нами був голова пожежної служби Берліна,
Карстен Гомрігаузен.
Щиро дякую за бесіду.
Така проблема актуальна не лише у Берліні.
У сусідньому Бранденбурзі
приблизно 12% загальної площі федеральної землі
засмічено бомбами, гранатами та боєприпасами -
небезпечною спадщиною з часів Другої світової війни
та від різних полігонів, зокрема радянських.
Щороку необхідно знищувати сотні тонн боєприпасів.
За інформацією від експертів, сильна спека
може змусити гранати розриватися.
А зараз у нас дійсно сильна спека.
Додамо до цього посуху, яка шкодить усім лісам
незалежно від того, чи зберігаються там боєприпаси.
Цього року Бранденбург уже
боровся з лісовими пожежами
і найсильнішою посухою в історії федеральної землі.
Кліматична криза лише погіршує ситуацію.
Настав час усе докорінно переосмислити.
Більше розповість Ян Меєр із Потсдама.
У сосновому лісі Томаса Вебера
цьогоріч вже здіймалася пожежа.
Проте її вдалося швидко згасити,
адже лісник регулярно прибирає
сухе гілля й повалені дерева.
Полум'ю не було чим живитися.
Велике значення має
так зване «пожежне навантаження».
Якщо у мене багато паливних матеріалів
і на території значно підвищується температура,
тоді динаміка поширення вогню інша,
ніж коли тут нічого немає і вогонь тліє на землі
або неінтенсивно горить.
Зовсім інший вигляд мали осередки пожежі
у Південному Бранденбурзі та Саксонії.
Суха деревина на землі посприяла
швидкому поширенню полум'я.
Такі ініціатори горіння є не лише тут.
Деякі експерти вважають,
що у висушених соснових лісах Бранденбурга
для запобігання пожежам людям
треба докласти неабияких зусиль.
У теперішніх умовах
потрібно негайно йти в ліс
і прибирати суху деревину.
Її можна переробити на тріски чи  пелети.
Так можна виробляти відновлювану енергію
і водночас позбавляти ліс ризику виникнення пожежі.
У здоровому лісі сухостої забезпечують різноманітність.
Але Бранденбург - це земля з високим ступенем ризику,
адже ніде не буває таких частих пожеж.
Окрім того, багато регіонів засмічені боєприпасами.
Гасіння вимагає дедалі більше
працівників та обладнання.
У Технічному університеті прикладних наук Вільдау
інженер авіації Вольфганг Рютер-Кіндель
планує до 2024 року
розробити новий тип безпілотника.
Він зможе перебувати в повітрі до восьми годин
і збирати над лісом у вогні інформацію
в режимі реального часу,
застосовуючи камеру.
Дрони використовуються вже сьогодні,
але для того, щоб інформація дійшла
до командного автомобіля,
потрібно забагато часу.
Увечері міністр екології Бранденбурга
відвідав знищений сосновий ліс
в районі Ельба-Ельстер.
Він вважає, що перетворення соснового лісу на мішаний
найкраще запобігатиме виникненню пожеж.
Однак політик з партії Зелених змушений визнати,
що його федеральна земля дедалі більше
відстає у реалізації задуму.
Це завдання для кількох поколінь.
У Бранденбурзі ми маємо перетворити
600 тис. га соснових лісів на мішані.
В одному з таких лісів ми,
до речі, перебуваємо просто зараз.
Ми розуміємо, що перетворення 5 тис. га лісу щороку -
насправді незначний результат.
Заміна дерев родини соснових на листяні потребує часу.
Лісник Вебер посадив у своєму окрузі дерева різних родин.
Такий мішаний ліс, де завжди прохолодно та волого,
має нижчий рівень пожежної небезпеки.
Навіть якщо хтось необачно викине тут сигарету,
пожежа почнеться не одразу.
Саме тому перетворення лісів -
неабияк важливе та нагальне завдання
для охорони від пожеж.
Томас Вебер хотів би, щоб «план Маршалла»
реалізували для лісів усього Бранденбурга.
Цього року він посадив дуби
і сподівається, що вони ще краще протистоятимуть
майбутнім хвилям спеки.
«План Маршалла» для всього лісу.
На Тайвані люди затамувавши подих
занепокоєно спостерігають за тим,
як Китай намагається залякати їх, демонструючи
свою військову міць.
Детальніше розповість Ханна.
Лише вчора
спікерка Палати представників США Ненсі Пелосі
відвідала Тайвань,
а вже сьогодні Китай розпочав
найбільші за останні десятиліття військові навчання
навколо острова.
Під час навчань військові Китаю випустили
безліч балістичних ракет.
Військові кораблі та винищувачі розташовані
всього за кілька кілометрів від узбережжя острова.
Уряд Тайваню привів свої збройні сили
у стан підвищеної бойової готовності.
За даними, військові маневри
Китаю триватимуть до неділі.
Вчора стало зрозуміло,
яким буде новий Закон «Про захист від інфекцій».
Відреагували на нього досить неоднозначно.
Президент Федеральної медичної асоціації Німеччини
Клаус Райнхардт
розкритикував проєкт, стверджуючи, що він надто нечіткий.
В інтерв'ю видавництву «Funke Mediengruppe» він заявив,
що незрозуміло те, що ж станеться,
якщо медична інфраструктура буде перевантажена.
Очільник Товариства німецьких лікарень Ґеральд Ґас
висловив подібну думку.
А зазначене в проєкті табу на закриття шкіл на карантин
викликало схвальні відгуки.
Відтепер знову можна отримати лікарняний
лише зателефонувавши в лікарню.
Це рішення ухвалив
Федеральний об'єднаний комітет лікарів, лікарень
та медичних страхових компаній.
Причина - високі показники захворюваності на коронавірус.
Тому, якщо ви застудилися, більше не треба йти в лікарню.
Лікарі та лікарки можуть
виписувати пацієнтам лікарняний
терміном до семи днів після телефонної консультації.
Це також стосується продовження лікарняного
ще на сім днів.
Спеціальне правило діє до кінця листопада.
Через численні обвинувачення
директорки телемережі «RBB»
(Rundfunk Berlin-Brandenburg) Патриції Шлезінгер
телеканал більше не головуватиме
у телерадіоконсорціумі «ARD».
Шлезінгер критикували, зокрема,
за укладання вигідних контрактів.
Її також підозрюють в непотизмі.
Як зазначила сама Шлезінгер, нині її головне завдання -
допомогти прояснити ситуацію.
Наразі 61-річна жінка залишається на посаді
директорки телеканалу «RBB».
Тепер в «ARD» головуватиме
телеканал «WDR» (Westdeutscher Rundfunk).
ООН заявляє, що готується дорозслідування
обстрілу табору військовополонених на Сході України.
Про це заявив Генеральний секретар ООН Антоніу Гутерреш.
За даними російської сторони,
минулої п'ятниці внаслідок вибухів у таборі
загинули десятки українських військовополонених.
Нині цю територію
контролюють російські військові.
Москва та Київ звинувачують одне одного в нападі.
Обидві сторони
подали запити ООН про проведення розслідування.
Чорнобиль розташований в Україні.
І лише назви достатньо,
щоб одразу ж загадати про давно забуті страхи.
Запорізька АЕС також розташована в Україні.
Це найбільша атомна електростанція Європи.
Але, що більше часу минає,
то більше вона перетворюється на театр воєнних дій.
Не треба бути експертом,
щоб уявити можливі наслідки.
Надходять повідомлення про те,
що російські війська, які зараз контролюють електростанцію,
обстріляли звідти сусіднє місто.
Вони, певно, покладаються на те,
що українці навряд чи зможуть відкрити вогонь у відповідь,
не вразивши станцію.
Жодна зі сторін не виявила готовності
домовитися про «зону безпеки»
хоча б навколо атомних електростанцій.
Про це повідомляє
Міжнародне агентство з атомної енергії (МАГАТЕ)
і водночас попереджає, що це не припустимо.
Докладніше - Камран Зафіаріан.
Березень 2022 року.
Атомна електростанція у Запоріжжі, найбільша в Європі,
перебуває під російським обстрілом.
Тоді «пощастило»,
адже ракети не вразили енергоблоки
та критично важливі системи.
Атомна електростанція розташована
у центрі зони бойових дій.
Як повідомляє МАГАТЕ,
ситуація вкрай загрозлива.
Агентство попереджає про можливість ядерної аварії.
Ситуація на ЗАЕС повністю вийшла з-під контролю.
Ми регулярно отримуємо інформацію
про обстріли з літаків або безпілотників.
Фізична цілісність АЕС була порушена.
Коли ми аналізуємо ситуацію на станції,
то розуміємо, що порушено
практично всі принципи ядерної безпеки.
Україна має чотири активні атомні електростанції,
загалом 15 енергоблоків.
ЗАЕС має шість енергоблоків,
три з яких зараз активні.
Атомна електростанція розташована
на Південному Сході України.
Це кадри 2016 року.
Навіть тоді обладнання було застарілим
та потребувало технічного обслуговування.
Несправностей стає дедалі більше.
Зараз АЕС контролює російська сторона.
За словами Рафаеля Гроссі,
ланцюжок постачань обладнання та запчастин
був перерваний.
Це парадоксальна ситуація,
адже станцію контролюють російські військові,
а український персонал
продовжує керувати ядерними операціями.
Це призводить
до неминучих моментів напруженості
та насильства.
Гроссі повідомляє про можливе викрадення
російською стороною співробітників АЕС.
А за словами Державного секретаря США Ентоні Блінкена,
Росія використовує
найбільшу атомну електростанцію в Європі
як військову базу та щит.
Росія використовує електростанцію
як військову базу для обстрілу України.
Вони знають, що Україна не може стріляти у відповідь,
тому що можуть випадково вразити ядерний реактор
або високорадіоактивні речовини.
Заступник міністра закордонних справ України
Микола Точицький
вимагає закриття повітряного простору
над атомними електростанціями України.
За словами експертів, якщо вразять АЕС,
варто очікувати найгіршого сценарію.
Ми маємо справу з новим виміром війни.
Насамперед під час ведення бойових дій
військові враховують велику небезпеку
атомних електростанцій.
Російська армія перетворює це місце на військову базу,
Україна також атакує його бойовими безпілотниками.
Якщо вони завдадуть значних пошкоджень,
це спричинить величезну ядерну аварію,
великомасштабне радіоактивне забруднення,
яке досягне і Європи.
Щоб запобігти цьому,
МАГАТЕ вимагає терміновий доступ
до атомної електростанції в Запоріжжі,
яку окупували російські військові.
МАГАТЕ стверджує, що за весь час використання
ядерної енергетики
ще ніколи не було подібної ситуації, коли одна держава
розв'язує повномасштабну загарбницьку війну
проти іншої держави, де розташовані атомні електростанції.
Тому реалістично оцінити можливі наслідки не можна.
Це звучить зовсім не райдужно.
Складна ситуація у світі, і в не менш складній ситуації
опинилася найкраща американська баскетболістка
Бріттні Ґрайнер.
У її багажі знайшли дві електронні сигарети
з гашишною олією,
і тепер вона має відбути дев'ять років за ґратами
за контрабанду наркотиків у Росії.
Вона благала російських суддів, але вони
не виявили милосердя.
Тепер її єдина надія - обмін полоненими,
а на президента Джо Байдена чинять величезний тиск.
Докладніше про це - Клаудія Бейтс.
Бріттні Ґрайнер розбита та шокована
під час оголошення вироку суддею.
Дев'ять років ув'язнення -
максимальне покарання, яке міг призначити суд.
Суд врахував здебільшого доводи сторони обвинувачення
та майже повністю проігнорував аргументи захисту.
Перед винесенням вироку
Бріттні Ґрайнер ще раз наголосила,
що діяла неумисно.
Я припустилася невинної помилки
та сподіваюся, що, згідно з Вашим вироком,
я не залишуся за ґратами до кінця свого життя.
Усі говорять про те, що я - політичний пішак,
що якось пов'язана з політичними іграми.
Але я сподіваюся, що думка Суду інша.
Московський аеропорт.
Вона прибула сюди, щоб грати за російську команду,
поки у США перерва між сезонами.
Під час перевірки її багажу виявили гашишну олію.
За її словами, вона збирала речі швидко, бездумно.
Іноді їй потрібен був канабіс для зняття болю.
Уряд США звинувачує Росію у тому, що це
політично мотивований судовий процес.
Суд ухвалив помилковий вирок.
Державний департамент США встановив,
що пані Ґрайнер ув'язнили неправомірно.
Ніщо в цьому вироку не змінює цієї оцінки.
Міністр закордонних справ Блінкен,
Рада національної безпеки США,
а також увесь уряд сповнені рішучості
повернути Бріттні Ґрайнер додому, до друзів та родини.
Уряд США вже запропонував обмін ув'язненими:
ми готові віддати російського контрабандиста зброї
Віктора Бута,
який перебуває за ґратами в США.
В обмін на Бута Росія має звільнити Бріттні Ґрайнер,
а також американця Пола Вілана,
ув'язненого в Росії.
Але на думку США, Росія вимагає не тільки
повернення Віктора Бута.
РФ хоче звільнення Вадима Красикова,
який в Берліні
скоїв вбивство на замовлення
державних органів Росії.
Я був би шокований, якби він став частиною обміну.
Вони завжди вимагають більше,
аж до останньої секунди.
Такий висновок я підбив із власного досвіду.
Це схоже не блеф, щоб зрештою
досягти укладення угоди.
Президент Байден висловився у письмовій формі
про винесення вироку Ґрайнер.
Росія незаконно утримує Бріттні. Це неприпустимо,
я вимагаю, щоб Росія негайно звільнила Ґрайнер,
аби вона могла бути разом зі своєю дружиною,
рідними, друзями та колегами з команди.
«Я люблю свою сім'ю», - такими
були її слова під час ув'язнення
Бріттні прагне оскаржити винесене рішення.
Фібі Гаа, наша кореспондентка, зараз перебуває в Москві.
Це дуже суворий вирок.
Яку причетність до цього має політика?
Ввезення канабісу в Росію та його
зберігання на території країни
карається позбавленням волі терміном
від п'яти до десяти років.
Вирок вмотивований саме цим законом.
Але якщо обвинувачений не є громадянином
«недружніх держав»,
до яких належать США та Німеччина,
вирок, як правило, має бути меншим.
Про те, що Росія хоче заробити на цій справі
політичний капітал,
стало зрозуміло не пізніше минулого тижня,
а саме під час телефонної розмови
міністрів закордонних справ Росії та Америки.
Це був перший прямий контакт
після вторгнення Росії в Україну.
Темою розмови була справа Ґрайнер
і можливий початок обміну.
Чи можна оцінити
наскільки ймовірним буде обмін ув'язненими,
в якому може бути залучена і Німеччина?
Вашингтон, здається, готовий до обміну
на російського контрабандиста зброї Віктора Бута.
Вважається, що він постачав нелегальну зброю
повстанцям і автократам у всьому світу.
Натомість Вашингтон хоче повернути Ґрайнер і Вілана.
Здається, Росії цього недостатньо.
Згідно з американськими даними,
РФ вимагає звільнення Вадима Красикова.
Це чоловік, який, за даними німецького суду,
застрелив громадянина Грузії у Берліні на замовлення
державних органів РФ.
Москва це завжди заперечувала.
Тепер Вашингтон повідомляє,
що Москва хоче залучити до угоди
засудженого вбивцю з третьої країни.
Це може зірвати серйозну пропозицію Вашингтона.
Ситуація між державами нагадує
«торги» з обміну ув'язненими.
Дякую, це був репортаж Фібі Гаа.
Після коронавірусної кризи компанія «Lufthansa»
очікує прибуток сумою понад пів мільярда євро
вже у цьому році.
Авіакомпанія також передбачає
подальші масштабні труднощі
та хаос під час реєстрації рейсів.
Сьогодні «Lufthansa» вже замріяно
поглядає у бік готелю поблизу аеропорту у Франкфурті.
Тільки-но відбулися переговори,
та вже за кілька хвилин стало очевидно,
що вони пройшли успішно.
«Lufthansa» і профспілка «Ver.di» змогли досягти згоди
щодо тарифних перемовин для наземного персоналу.
Стефані Баррет перебуває у Франкфурті.
Стефані, що відомо наразі?
Очевидно, що клієнти «Lufthansa»
можуть зітхнути з полегшенням -
хаос страйків має закінчитися.
Сторони досягли певного прогресу
у конфлікті щодо тарифних перемовин.
Згідно зі словами «Verdi» 20 тис.
наземних співробітників «Lufthansa»
отримають підвищення зарплати в три етапи,
спочатку додана сума становитиме 200 євро на місяць.
Підвищення відбуватиметься
з липня до січня:
з 1 січня очікується збільшення на 2,5%,
тобто щонайменше 125 євро на місяць,
та ще на 2,5% з липня наступного року.
«Lufthansa» виборола свою позицію
щодо терміну дії тарифів,
який тепер становить 18 місяців.
Профспілка ж вимагала 12 місяців, щоб мати змогу
швидше скоригувати тарифи у разі розвитку інфляції.
Але сторони задоволені результатом.
Компанія «Lufthansa» вперше після коронакризи
повністю в плюсі.
Тепер, коли конфлікт із заробітною платою,
схоже, вирішено,
авіакомпанія має дві причини для святкування,
оскільки вона знову «у плюсі»
після найбільшої авіаційної кризи
з часів післявоєнного періоду.
У другому кварталі, тобто з квітня до червня,
компанія отримала прибуток
компанія отримала прибуток обсягом
близько 260 млн євро,
минулого року в цей час вона потерпала від збитків
обсягом близько 760 млн євро.
Хоча було продано набагато більше квитків
для пасажирських перевезень
зрештою, у другому кварталі авіакомпанією «Lufthansa»
скористалися близько 29 млн пасажирів,
більшу частину прибутку було отримано переважно
завдяки вантажним перевезенням.
Так, підрозділ «Lufthansa Cargo»,
який вже отримав рекордний прибуток минулого року,
хоче знову повторити це досягнення.
Щодо персоналу, «Lufthansa» прагне найняти 10 тис.
нових співробітників до наступного року,
щоб усунути проблему нестачі кадрів.
Можна лише побажати удачі.
Принаймні сьогодні інвестори поділяють цей оптимізм,
тому акції компанії зросли на 6,4%
в індексі MDax.
Однак, дивує, зокрема, й оптимізм керівництва
компанії «Lufthansa»
на тлі численних криз.
Дякую Стефані за репортаж з Франкфурта.
Британський центральний банк знову підвищив
процентні ставки.
І досить сильно, на пів відсотка, до 1,75%.
Такий чіткий крок Велика Британія
не робила з 1990-х років.
Підґрунтя заклав стабільно високий рівень інфляції
у Великій Британії.
Останнім часом він становив 9,4%.
Сумний проміжний підсумок цього купального сезону:
згідно з даними асоціації рятувальників DLRG
до кінця липня в Німеччині потонуло 199 осіб.
Це на 15 постраждалих більше,
ніж за аналогічний період
минулого року, і на думку асоціації рятувальників,
це пов'язано з раннім початком купального сезону.
Вже в травні велика кількість людей купалася у холодній воді.
Найбільше нещасних випадків сталося на річках,
озерах та місцях для купання, де немає рятувальників.
Ісландія славиться своєю природою:
На південному заході країни знову почалося
виверження вулкана.
Від учора лава витікає з 300-метрової прірви.
Це приваблює безліч глядачів до місцевості,
яка прилягає до столиці Рейк'явік.
Скільки триватиме це видовище, поки невідомо:
минулого року виверження вулкана неподалік
тривало майже пів року.
Ми можемо запропонувати вам ще одну подорож
разом із кореспондентом ZDF з Південної Америки
Крістофом Рекератом.
Ми вирушимо через таємничі Анди
до офіційного кінця світу,
де гори занурюються
у крижані води Південної Атлантики.
Захопливо?
Після новин ми перенесемо вас у спекотну літню ніч.
Чекайте на випуск «heute journal:update» о 0:36.
Добрий вечір і ласкаво просимо до прогнозу погоди.
Надзвичайну спеку витіснить
холодний фронт, який прибув до нас
з північного заходу.
Він принесе сильні зливи та грози в найближчі години.
Гаряче повітря продовжує надходити
до нас з півдня.
Тому завтра на півдні позначка
термометра покаже 35°С.
А тепер детальніше:
вночі на північному заході та заході
пройдуть рясні дощі з грозами.
Очікується непогода, яка супроводжуватиметься
градом, шквалами
і великою кількістю опадів за короткий час.
На південному сході буде тихо,
на Півночі очікується найнижча температура - до 14°С,
-  і 22°С на сході.
Тож там буде справжня тропічна ніч,
як і у напрямку Рейн-Майн.
На заході і півночі завтра вранці
пройдуть сильні зливи та грози,
на півдні - сонячно.
Але вдень холодний фронт рухатиметься
далі на південь.
А потім знову на півдні очікуємо грози
з градом, поривами вітру, а також зливами.
На північному заході поступово все вщухатиме,
найвища температура на півдні - до 35°С.
Особливо в напрямку Баварії, 34°С в напрямку Ниси-Лужицької
і 20°С поблизу Північного моря.
Наступні дні:
у суботу на півдні йтимуть зливи та грози,
температура - до 27°С.
З неділі температури знову зростатимуть.
Гарного вечора!